Florida family believes an officer who
hit and killed their loved one should
have lost his badge before the deadly
crash 62 year-old Blaine land was
crossing the street in May when Officer
Timothy James crashed into him land died
from his injuries
officer James was responding to a
robbery call the incident was ruled an
accident
when lands family and their attorney
began investigating this crash they
found the officer had nearly a dozen
complaints against him
Omar Villafranca this morning looks at
their search for justice not having the
answers it absolutely does delay your
grieving Stacy land was heartbroken
after her brother Blaine was struck and
killed in May by an on-duty Jacksonville
sheriff's officer responding to a call
officer Timothy L James was immediately
put on administrative leave but never
arrested one month later the same
officer was arrested for allegedly
beating a handcuffed teenager
James has pleaded not guilty to the
beating he has been reassigned to desk
duty and stripped of his law enforcement
powers but the alleged beating may not
be an isolated incident a Jacksonville
Sheriff's Office document shows that 11
complaints have been filed against
officer James since 2014 charges include
violating firearms policy and lying to
supervisors James received a 10-day
suspension for the latter in April cell
phone footage surfaced of what appears
to be officer Tim James spitting on a
man outside a hospital James has not
responded to our request for an
interview the Jacksonville Sheriff's
Department says Florida law protects
officers privacy we cannot identify an
officer under investigation
but Stacy land wanted to know more her
lawyer put in a public records request
for more information on officer James
and the department's history the
sheriff's office sent an invoice
totaling three hundred and fourteen
thousand six hundred eighty seven
dollars and 91 cents it was ridiculous
it's clearly meant to dissuade us from
looking further the sheriff's office
said the request was broad and included
all of the materials in a sixteen
hundred cubic foot room
also like to correct against some of
that narrative the South air that we
have you know been obstructionist and
charts 300 grand for one officers record
when that's just not completely accurate
officer James is just one of seven
Jacksonville officers who have been
arrested since January charges against
the other officers include tampering
with evidence and aggravated assault
prosecutors have dropped charges in 41
cases that rely on testimony of recently
arrested officers as for Stacy land she
says she wants justice for her brother
my brother's debt to me is is the
perfect storm out of a broken department
with messed up processes and people
looking the other way and an officer who
should not be on the street
for CBS this morning Omar Villafranca